- Notre gestion, elle est
- De nature joviale, la mairesse
de Montréal retenait à peine
sa colère aujourd'hui en
se présentant devant les médias.
son administration a été
par des reportages
sur l'utilisation des fonds
octroyés par Québec pour
dans la métropole.VALÉRIE PLANT,
mairesse de Montréal
- On laissera pas personneégrit.
L'intégrité de notre
administration, mais également
l'intégrité de l'institution
qu'est la Ville deurces avaiurcé
à Radio-Canada, jeudi soir, que,
bien que l'impression ne soit
pas généralisée, certains
fonctionation de montants
destinés au Service de police
de la Ville de Montréal.
- On va être clair, l'argent
L'argent qui est prévu pour
l'habitation va à l'habitation.
les parcs va pour les parcs.
- Depuis mercredi dernier,
un comité d'experts évalue les
pour demander davantage d'argent
c. Et c'est dans
ce contexte que l'administration
Plante aà certaines décisions ss
dépenses d'argent destinées
à la sécurité publique.
Certains médias ont même
Plante était soupçonnée d'avoir
détournént au point
d'avoir fait un définancement
déguisé de la police
- Là, j'en ai assez qu'on fasse
peur au monde, qu'on fasse peur
aux policiers et aux policières
en disant que notre
administration veut définancer.
C'est faux!
- Rarement aura-t-on vu
la mairesse de Montréal sortir
de ses gonds sur un préjugé
antipolice qui colle à son parti
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir.
- Ça n'a jamais
et ça n'aura jamais lieu.
- Sur les ondes du 98,5 FM,
la ministre de la Sécurité
publique, Geneviève Guilbault,
a voulu calmer le jeu
rant sa corant sa corant sa core
envers Valérie Plante.
- Nous, on fait confiance
à l'administration,
puis tu sais, je veux dire,
moi, je fais confiance
à Mme Plante, je anceanceanceane
à l'administration municipale
à Montréal.
- Afin de mettre cette situation
derrière eux rapidement,
le gouvernement du Québec et
la Ville de Montréal pourraient
conjointement faire une annonce
en matière de lutte contre
la violence armée avant
le déclenchement des élections
prévu di